GOOD AFTERNOON WILL CALL TO
ORDER THE COMMITTEE ON UTILITIES
AND ENERGY.
FOR JANUARY ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO
COURTS ARE BUT BROKE. A LITTLE.
WE ARE IN A HURRY TO GET OUT BUT
NOT.
HOLDEN PRESENT.
CHáVEZ FAIR.
BURKE.
CHEN.
CUNNINGHAM THERE EGGMAN HERE
FONG. GARCIA HERE.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
MAYES.
RCG.
QUIRK CARE RAZ.
SANTIAGO.
TING.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM. HOW WE DO
HAVE ONE ITEM TO TAKE UP BUT
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
HOUSEKEEPING BEFOREHAND R. REUS
AND MAYES WILL NOT BE HERE
THEY'VE BEEN EXCUSE FOR IT FROM
TODAY'S HEARING?
SO WHENEVER CUNNINGHAM IS
SPILLING INFORMATION WE WELCOME
HIM.
WE ALSO HAVE A NEW CHEER VICE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE AND WE
WANT TO WELCOME.
MISTER CHAVEZ AND YOU KNOW SEE
IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS THAT
YOU LIKE TO.
NOW I OFFER HAD BEEN HERE FOR
FIVE YEARS. PARENT MOVEMENT
THERE'D OVER HERE.
OKAY ROY.
.
PHONE SERVICE TO CUTTING HIM
WELCOME.
THANK YOU DEATH I MEAN TO PUT
YOU IN IT TEMPORARY CATEGORY BUT
YES THANK YOU WELCOME AND IF
THERE'S ANY. NO NO NO I HAVE.
YOU'RE GOOD.
I.
.
FOR.
SO GOOD SO WILL LOOK TO YOU IF
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS THAT YOU
LIKE TO SHARE THAT'S NOT
NECESSARY BUT IF YOU DO.
WELCOME.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A SHORTAGE AND
THERE WE HAVE ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO QUIRK SILVA
WHICH IS ON.
R. CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECOND. IT'S WITHOUT ITS WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
THERE THE THE AUTHOR HAS.
AGREED TO THE AMENDMENTS
AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
TENNIS AYE TO MOVE FOR LET ME
JUST STATE FOR THE RECORD THAT
THE.
AUTHOR IS COMMITTED TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENT SAYS DETAILED ANALYSIS
AND COMMENTS.
FOR SIX SEVEN AND EIGHT IN THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS AND THEY
WILL BE TAKEN UP ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SO IF THERE IS NO COMMENT OR.
DISCUSSION ON THE MOTION THERE'S
BEEN IN. TO APPROVE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR A ROLL CALL ON THE
MOTION.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HOLDEN. BY HOLDEN
AYE. CHáVEZ. CHáVEZ AYE.
BURKE.
CHEN AYE CHEN AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE.
FONG.
FONG AYE PRISONERS HERE.
CHRISTINA GARCIA AYE EDUARDO
GARCIA.
PURSUIT SHE.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
TING.
OF VERY.
THE THERE ARE. EIGHT MEMBERS IN
FAVOR NO OPPOSED WE WILL LEAVE
THE.
WELL YEAH THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES TO GIVE OTHER
MEMBERS AN OPPORTUNITY COMING IN
VOTE.
NO.
OKAY.
HE WILL TAKE UP ADD ONS ON THE.
AB ARE COMING AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
TWO QUIRK SILVA.
THE CHAIR IN FAVOR.
MURATSUCHI I.
MURATSUCHI AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
BURKE.
SANTIAGO TING
VERY AND I TEXTED YEAH WE DON'T
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING.
ADDING ON TO AB FIFTEEN FIFTY
TWO QUIRK SILVA WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE CALLING ABSENT
MEMBERS BURKE AYE. BURKE AYE
EDUARDO GARCIA.
SANTIAGO TEAM
CALLING OUT FIFTY TWO QUIRK
SILVA.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE. TING
.
ONE OF.
I DON'T.
ON THE.
WE. HOPE
AB FIFTEEN TO FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO
ADDING ON CON AFTER MEMBERS
EDUARDO GARCIA TING. TING AYE
.
FORWARD
WE HAVE TWELVE VOTES IN FAVOR
OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. WE ADJOURN